it's a real pleasure to
have you here and you know pleasure to
be here we've heard from a lot of you
know amazing ukrainian women over the
weeks um but you know to actually meet
somebody as they're traveling to the uk
is that you know it is a privilege to
happen to say thank you thank you um
now you're part of the resistance in
ukraine you know as i said in the
introduction you know you kind of joked
that training is a good workout but it's
not great for the manicure you know how
to shoot a gun you've been training for
two hours a day can you just talk a bit
about your experience your life must
have completely
changed since the announcement of war
yeah it absolutely changed
and
the setting it will never be the same
again
you know um i was traveling right now by
the time path as ukraine refugees do
when they leave ukraine
and everybody was so great along the way
uh in poland and moving forward and here
in the uk
so uh on the first morning i was jogging
in warsaw
and there was an ambulance passing by
with we will and i realized that in one
minute i'm on the ground with my head
hovering my head
and so for the last three months
i have been standing still doing
everything possible and impossible i
realized that the trauma
that ukrainian people are getting that
i'm getting is something that
that is there that will never go away
this is what we are talking about when
we are saying that uh the trauma on our
children in different ages would be
something
that is irreparable
and it's for generation right now you
know like uh we were hoping that we will
raise up all the children that uh don't
know the poverty the war the revolutions
that we would spoil them and make sure
that they will be
when they will be grown up they will be
able to build new advanced ukraine and
right now we are robbed of that
and my life in ukraine as politician as
a member of resistance
um
it's just completely different from
anything i could have ever imagined what
is it like can you give us an insight
like where are you living what was the
typical day
so i i stay at home
i still have resistance members staying
with me
they are training and i'm training with
them
we are training to shoot we are training
some some
advancements and how to protect the
territory where we are we are right now
part of the major resistance
of kiev region
and some of the people have been already
deployed to war
and some of the members of my team will
also be redeployed soon
i cook something that i never have done
before we still have
uh one month's supplies of food and
water at home
because it's so scary you know
the scary thing was it will be no water
and i was thinking i don't want to die
dirty so i have like lots of water
everywhere i actually like to yeah
no but this is something when you're
talking to refugees from haki from
heavily bombarded areas when they are
saying uh well like the the most
complicated thing was when the
electricity went down when the water
went went off so like what are you what
are you supposed to do you have to get
ready for everything i have um
uh so i have chargers and power banks
everywhere and make sure that they are
charged in case uh in case we will have
to use them so you live in this constant
inability to exhale
and say okay yeah we are safe right now
because every single day
there are air raid sirens there are
attacks on kiev and on other major
cities of ukraine and the war it did not
go anywhere they active fighting went to
the east but the threat
the fear
it is still there as you said that that
is a fear that you will always bear with
you at least yes yeah that's that's
something that that is already with me
and i realize it so strongly right now
um do you think you'll ever feel safe
again
well
here i feel safe but i'll have to come
back home because this is the fight that
we have to put up and we have to win
and
i dream of the day when when all
ukrainians will be able to feel safe
when we will you know be able to sit
put your
uh hands
on your lap and say yeah okay
we are okay now
and more important is that our children
will be able to do so
because right now so yes there was at
the protest in the downing streets at
the rallies of ukrainian people and
people say we feel
so uncomfortable that we had to leave we
feel so great that people are
supporting us but we feel guilty that we
had to leave and i say don't
you make sure that your children are not
going through this terror that i'm not
going through this trauma and you need
to make sure that they are safe and this
is what your obligation as a parent to
make them safe
this is why i am telling to ukrainian
people wherever you are we are all
together we are standing together and we
are supporting our country and every
single person is doing it their own way
and this is why
uh it's so important is this why this
trip is so important that i was able to
talk to them and to support them and to
hear from them
um let's talk a bit about the the visit
as you say you've been meeting uh
politicians here in the uk what is it
specifically you've been asking for and
if you had any reassurances so uh i'm
having actually important meeting with
the defense committee tomorrow
and before that there are three things
that i'm actually asking for
the first one is the
wide range missiles this is something
that we critically need to make sure
that we fight russians back you have
heard that they have been advancing in
the east and we do need more weapons and
we need specific weapons that we know
that will help us
the second point is
the
visa waiver for ukrainians there is you
know
the united kingdom is very far from
ukraine there are not so many people
getting in but for the ones who are
uh i i'm uh humbly asking
for making it easier on them what is the
process like is it too bureaucratic we
haven't had a bureaucratic it's long and
uh and it's complicated and these are
refugees yeah they don't have the
paperwork yes and you see like um
britain has been one of our closest
allies so ukrainians right now travel
without visas through the eu uh there
are the processes have been eased up for
us and canada so it's just a question
mark for me why united kingdom wouldn't
do the same it would be just only
natural and again we are we are talking
about maybe 20 000 people who would get
it eased up
so on them so i think this is completely
doable and the third thing is sorry
about the ports
so before the war
ukraine was top three producers of the
world grains sunflower oil
uh wheat
for tomatoes and corn so tell me which
ones you don't like which ones you want
to get rid of and so right now it is all
blocked in ukraine and we are unable to
to actually deliver it anywhere because
of the blocked ports so there is an
extreme need right now to get into
humanitarian mission to be able to
extract all this produce i have talked
to people here i know you guys are
having already uh higher food prices
which we just talked about just the yeah
sunflower oil is missing from the stores
you know why because it's all in ukraine
right now and the world right now has
only 10 weeks supplies
of grains 10 weeks for all the
politicians all the leaders of the world
to make sure that you figure out
how to how to get all the harvest that
ukraine has out so these are the three
key points that i'm pushing that i'm
working on to make sure that uh that
they actually make a real difference so
it's not like a political discussions
it's rather the executional discussions
let's get on that and do that it's
interesting to listen to those three
points it feels like with two of those
points the uk government is very on
board with we've been one of the leading
supplier of weapons we know that boris
johnson has spoken specifically to
president zielinski about the port
situation
i guess
is it the middle situation that the visa
requirement that you think the uk is
doing the worst on
of these three points probably it's just
like at the bottom of the list because
as my argument that there is not too
many people who need this waiver and the
government's argument as well there is
not too many people like let them go
through the process
but
i met those people i know them they they
are all people who just are they just
need the support people are not coming
to united kingdom to get like supports
from the government they usually come in
here because they have relatives or they
have friends or they have somebody to
support do you think there's a
reluctance with this government to to
open up the visa requirements there is
some i think it's just like saying okay
it's not into in our priorities and
that's why yeah
yeah well i want to make it a priority
okay um and just finally um
you know it's always difficult talking
about the specifics of what is happening
in ukraine i find it difficult to to
listen to i'm sure our viewers find it
difficult to listen to as well but there
is an importance to to bear witness and
to for us to to tell the world about
what is happening
you know you were speaking very movingly
about children and the impact on
children at the beginning of the
interview and i just wondered if you
wanted to leave
us with any examples of the kind of
thing that children are experiencing in
ukraine
i can give you a couple of examples so
at the very beginning of the war in the
bomb shelter
there was a toddler
whose mummy told him
his blood type
so he's barely speaking and when he's
asked what's your blood type
he's saying
there is a girl who was asking her mommy
the question that nobody can answer for
real mommy are we refugees now
how are you supposed to to talk to your
kid about that
and there were these
group of children refugees from mariupol
who were handed over like without their
parents and their parents were giving
them the backpacks the small ones the
blue for boys and their painful girls
and they were putting
like the the small bare minimum there
and when and and mommies when they were
handing them over to strangers saying
just get them safe they were telling
hold on whatever what happens hold on to
your backpack and then when at the
refugee center you are hugging this
child and you are telling like give it
to me like please let's open up and
watch what's there. and he's saying no
mommy told me not to do that he told me
to do this and would i ever see my mommy
again and then when you open up
you know like the same same thing as
probably what happened during the world
second world war when they were writing
down like the small things like saying
mommy loves you this is his last name
first name this is his paperwork this is
our address and please please please
please please make him safe
this is what i want for ukrainian
children to make them safe thank you so
much
thank you thank you for coming on the
program i'm sorry i'm very emotional um
but you know it's hard to hear
face-to-face some of what happening
thank you